did you see cnn say that uh
rogan is the new january 6th right
unbelievable and then i think they
switched the headline was it you to
point that out no i pointed that out
doug pointed out so the initial headline
was
that rogan joe rogan saying the n word
is another january january 6 mo [ __ ]
crazy and then they switched it to
why joe rogan's n-word is like so
dangerous or something like that exactly
a hundred percent i mean i screenshotted
it you could see it on the writer's page
as well and then it was just swap people
are like it's unbelievable i wonder if
they realize that it's all coming
crumbling it wasn't an opinion piece it
was it was an analyst it was a cnn
analyst so i'm like that's more really
do they realize it's over
like do they realize it's over
cnn no what part over that we don't care
about rogue and we're going to get
people don't care about them and that
they've lost all the faith so now
there's just national enquirer at this
point and just saying whatever i really
think so
and maybe i'm operating in a bubble
because you know we're podcasters and
like we're on youtube and we understand
that there are more sources for news
that might be a little bit more truthful
at least a little bit more objective
that's possible
but i wonder if they're ever looking at
this like wow our viewership is down 50
our brand has taken a massive hit and
people do not trust the media right now
and we are the media and that's
literally the only reason why we watch
right like if you're the news we got to
trust you're going to give us some truth
yeah
i think you're giving them too much
credit i think it's a sinking ship and
people on sinking ships aren't rational
i think it's a sinking ship and they're
thinking oh you know what buoyed our
ship before was trump trump was the
[ __ ] rising tide that lifted all of
our boats yeah we don't have trump right
now let's make a new one so we just got
to make somebody else trump and why not
the guy that's taking away from our
listenership and viewership as much as
like as much as anyone yeah but there's
why are they doing that why are they
trying to find another trump instead of
going back to what they were before
which was the first 24-hour news network
where they gotta hit the quarterly keep
on giving us the news
that's not fun that wasn't him
because 24-hour news has now they've
realized it has to be sticky it's not
about the most newsworthy story it's
about the story we'll tune in to tune
into the most i remember this like 15
years ago i was in college it was a
[ __ ] balloon boy remember the guy
that the kid they got trapped in the hot
air balloon across the world then they
found out they made the whole thing up
we were fascinated by that story and it
was on cnn all day and i was like yo
aren't we at war right now how are we
watching this [ __ ] balloon boy and
then i realized that's what we'll watch
all day yeah well i want to hear this
unfold oh lump is always going to give
you new things
and they're always going to try to make
new things because he's not really
giving them to you so let's find old
things and then let's find new things
rogan is cnn's pete davidson
yeah interesting
so the entertainment world it's pete
yeah and kanye yeah
and kim
those are the buzzwords or the buzz
names and for
news
it's [ __ ] rogan now man he's a
lightning rod wow
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
yeah yeah it's a shame it's a shame
because like if that's all they have
they're not going to let up anytime soon
well we could say also that was on the
you can go heavy on the opinion side and
then the other side was covid where it
was like turn it on at any time it's
like flashing breaking news yeah this is
now how you wash your hands they had a
[ __ ] death count and i'm a guy i took
cover seriously but we don't need a
[ __ ] death ticker yeah every death
you just add one to the board what the
[ __ ] is that yeah every episode was an
in memoriam and now that covet is over
and trump is gone what do we have until
2024 where they're praying to god trump
runs again i promise you they're gonna
cover him all the time all of a sudden
these little uh bans on trump are gonna
be lifted and they're gonna it's gonna
be like democrats suddenly lifting cove
bans so there's no more kovid and
there's no more trump so rogan replaces
both of them actually yes because he
because he gets to be the covenant
misinformation guy and he gets to be the
political opposition yes right even
though he's not but that's how they're
going together
i think all of us saw with the [ __ ]
all the liberal things joe rogan has
said yeah he's like i'm in favor of
universal health care yeah i love
universe basic universal basic income
and then he's like i think we should pay
more in taxes [ __ ] you for not you
republican piece of [ __ ] yeah we should
help inner city community it's like
every liberal thing you could possibly
say i've never voted republican in my
life he says
it's but nobody's playing that yeah they
won't go and cnn they just need to get
back to the news talking about sexy m
m's man
take notes from yeah
[Applause]